le procès charlie qui s'ouvre cette
semaine cinq ans après les attentats
contre la rédaction de charlie hebdo et
l'hyper cacher de vincennes lafont s'est
elle encore charlie on peut se poser
cette question
peut-être que l'unanimité vous vous
souvenez qu'il y avait mes 4 millions de
français dans la rue juste après les
attentats est derrière nous écoutez ce
témoignage c'est celui de richard malka
c'est l'avocat historique de charlie et
pour lui en quelque sorte les auteurs de
l'attentât ont gagné parce que la
liberté d'expression a plutôt reculé
depuis cinq ans c'était ce matin sur
france inter
vous dites les frères kwasi et coulibaly
ont gagné vraiment ils ont gagné alors
je crois que je dis qu'ils ont en tout
cas ils ont provisoirement gagner parce
que je pense que la liberté finit
toujours par l'emporter
je pense effectivement que
provisoirement leur état d'esprit a
gagné c'est à dire que si vous voyez
dans tous les champs de la liberté
d'expression il ya une régression
formidable
voilà et bien sûr on attend vos
réactions sur ce sujet vous connaissez
les hashtag point de vue et figaro live
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
jérôme sainte-marie est ce que la
liberté d'expression a plutôt reculé
depuis cinq ans ah oui certainement
certainement mais peut-être pas
exactement uniquement dans le sens je ne
sais pas ce que si longtemps monsieur
malka il a dit dans tout dans toutes ses
formes la liberté d'expression a reculé
bien entendu il ya même des lois pour ça
pour la faire reculer
je vous compagne secondes dans une autre
interview c'était au point il explique
aujourd'hui il est plus difficile de
critiquer l'islam parce que aussitôt et
notamment dans les rangs de la gauche ou
d'une certaine gauche
on vous accuse de racisme ou
d'islamophobie bah oui on and on a la
niaque des affaires récentes on a les
propos récents notamment venant de la
france insoumise mais la liberté
d'expression excusez moi ne se résume
pas à la critique de l'islam ou
l'immigration est ce que je constate
simplement c'est qu'il ya des lois qui
voient leurs oeuvres via été censurée
par le conseil constitutionnel mais
enfin il ya toute une série de luttes
contre les supposés fait news d'une
série effectivement de lutte contre la
skhira kull sur internet
c'est une forme de contrôle liberté
d'expression effectivement on ne peut
pas dire qu'en france on est une passion
particulière pour la liberté
d'expression ni pour le pluralisme
éthique donc ça les exemples abondent
encore une fois il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de s'intéresser à la question
de la critique de l'islam
quant à la critique de l'islam je trouve
quand même que le jugement me paraît
bien comment dirais-je je devrais pas
bien pessimiste parce que la critique de
l'islam n'est pas une valeur en soi mais
il me semble qu'on peut s'exprimer et
qu'on s'exprime encore très vivement
très librement sur le sujet ce qu'on va
essayer de faire d'ailleurs avec vous
dès à présent mathieu caire on se
souvient de cette formule je suis
charles et qui a été reprise par tous
les gens qui voulaient montrer leur
soutien à la rédaction de charlie hebdo
décimée par cet attentat
il ya un sondage il faut qui a été
commandé par charlie hebdo et qui montre
que il ya quand même un certain nombre
de français 8% et le taux monte à 18 %
chez les musulmans un certain nombre de
français qui se refuse à condamner
l'attentât contre charlie hebdo est ce
que ça vous inquiète est ce que vous y
voyez ainsi que toute la france n'est
pas charlie alors je suis pas du tout
inquiet et pas du tout d'accord non plus
avec ce que disait ce matin richard
malka et jean veut effectivement pour
illustration ce que ce que l' enquête de
l'ifop dont vous parlais à l'instant
permet de révéler une enquête de l'ifop
et de la fondation jean jaurès
notre fondation jean jaurès que j'ai
l'insigne honneur de représenter ici le
le chiffre le plus parlant me
semble-t-il issue de cette enquête c'est
celui qui consiste à dire que oui nous
sommes charlie en réalité nous sommes
charlie alors que nous n'avons pas
toujours été charles isme jeudi nous
sommes charlie parce que aujourd'hui la
grande majorité des français considèrent
que charlie a eu raison de publier ces
caricatures en 2006 en 2006 au moment de
la faire au moment de la polémique il
n'ya que 38% des français qui approuvent
le choix éditorial de charlie + 21
points en moins de 15 ans il est évident
que les attentats de 2015 on joue un
rôle considérable mais contrairement à
ce que dit richard richard malka
il y a dans l'opinion une volonté
d'affirmer cette liberté d'expression
qui est bien plus ancré aujourd'hui qui
hier est deuxième élément vous passiez
rapidement sur le mouvement qui avait
mis quatre millions de personnes dans la
rue en 2015
quatre millions de personnes dans
l'histoire de la france de la république
mais même au delà
c'est un score jamais atteint
jamais l'opinion française n'avait
manifesté une telle unanimité qu'à
l'occasion qu'à l'occasion de charlie il
y avait la défense de la liberté
d'expression dont je ne vois pas ce qui
permet de dire objectivement qu'elle est
aujourd'hui amputée qu'elle ait besoin
d'être régulé dans un monde où les
canaux d'information de communication et
de débats se sont démultipliés les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr mais même les
chaînes d'information en continu on
allume aujourd'hui sa télévision
du matin au soir on a des débatteurs des
gens qui librement peuvent s'emparer de
tous les sujets de société ça n'existait
pas il ya 20 ans donc aujourd'hui tout
le monde peut parler de tout tout le
temps y compris sur les réseaux sociaux
est donc parfois avec des arguments qui
sont si stéphane à cieux un style une
capacité à s'injurier à ne pas se
respecte et qui mérite d'être canalisée
mais encore une fois tout cela ne dit
pas que la liberté d'expression est
aujourd'hui menacé par ailleurs votre
mari je vous laisse répondre
j'ajoute simplement un élément leu leu
sur le point du sondage que vous citiez
plus exactement un chiffre effectivement
59% des français considèrent que charlie
hebdo a eu raison de publier les
caricatures de mahomet donc 20 % de plus
qu'il ya 15 ans voilà c'est ça donc dans
ce sondage ifop fondation jean jaurès
je trouve que ce qu'a fait la fondation
jean jaurès avec l'ifop est très
intéressant très intéressant quand on
regarde le détail des résultats mais à
des regroupements qu'il faut faire
attention à ne peut être pas faire je
lis partout j'entends partout y compris
à l'instant que 18% des musulmans ne
condamne pas des attentats en réalité la
question est posée de manière très
précise
on leur père on permet aux gens en
france aient à tout le monde devrait
dire vous voulez vous les condamnez
absolument et c'est machin ou bien un
item ne les condamne pas ne les condamne
pas seuls quatre ou cinq pour cent 5 %
je crois des musulmans choisissent je te
dire je ne les condamne pas ce qui
signifie quasiment là je les approuve
mais enfin bon moi je ne condamne pas
ces havres en prenant les nous mais
vainement pardon jérôme 5 % des
musulmans et 3% de l'ensemble de la
populaire et c'est uniquement en
additionnant assez 5%
ce les 13% qui ont choisi je ne me
prononce pas qu'on dit voulait
s'interrompt 10 18
condé 18% à 18 % voilà condé 18%
n'exprime pas de condamnation ça me
paraît quand même un peu rapide parce
que quand je dis quand j'en ai entendu
ni lu % moi j'ai compris dooyoo %
quasiment les approuver mais quand ça
sera différent ça veut dire je ne
condamne pas non attendez on ne condamne
pas comment je sais pas comment dire et
ça si on faisait ça pour tous les
sondages sur tous les sujets on aurait
des chiffres à kaboul sondeurs à calabar
dont la vitesse que c'est n'importe quoi
c'est encore une fois faut pas non plus
il ya suffisamment de sujets
d'inquiétudes ya suffisamment d'ailleurs
de d'attaqués terroristes etc pour ne
pas en rajouter là s'il voulait bon il
ya 5 % des gens qui disent je ne
condamne pas les attentats bon c'est
effectivement stade pour ce canal pour
cent des musulmans
c'est une vraie préoccupation 5% ça fait
du monde mais ce n'est pas 10 8% qui
sont en train de dire à un sondage qui
est en train d approuver ou en tout cas
je les condamne pas être indifférent on
a le droit je vais tout à fait sincère
on a le droit d'être indifférent à son
nombre de sujets on a le droit de ne pas
répondre à un sondage c'est un sondeur
qui vous le dit on à droit de pas avoir
d'opinion surtout et c'est donc il faut
faire qui peut il faut pas quand même
amalgame et des pourcentages de manière
à un contrôle et disons et il y à un
autre écart à nuancer c'est l'écart
entre les français qui condamne
effectivement ces attentats et les
français musulmans qui le condamne 88%
des français condamnent 71% des
musulmans
l'écart existe il est significatif mais
encore une fois il mérite d'être mesurés
d'être d'être nuancée aux trois quarts
nos compatriotes musulmans condamnent
évidemment les attentats de 2015
voilà donc je trouve qu'il ya parfois
comme le disait jérôme un fils qu'on
tire un tout petit peu dangereux un
autre chiffre a été tirée mis en exergue
c'est la proportion en fait de
françaises et de français musulmans qui
sont capables de mettre leurs croyances
religieuses au dessus des valeurs de la
république absolument c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des éléments du sondage que nous
voulions vous montrer oui l'a sans
parler il est évident que ce pourcentage
questionne questionne qu'aujourd'hui
encore un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes place leurs croyances
religieuses au dessus des valeurs de la
république
c'est nécessairement un problème et ça
chiffre même une forme de faillite de la
république au moins partiel mais
n'oublions pas que nos compatriotes
musulmans ne sont pas les soldes ne sont
pas les seuls les catholiques eux-mêmes
les catholiques eux mêmes et ça ne date
pas d'aujourd'hui là pour le coup c'est
l'histoire de la république
il s'est constitué et consolider en
opposition au pouvoir
catholique les catholiques eux-mêmes ont
longtemps placé leurs convictions
religieuses au dessus des valeurs elle a
répondu mais ça soyons plus précis
moi je vois grave tout de suite
d'ailleurs un set voyons on va la voir
tout de suite cette réponse à ceux à
cette question en général fait vous
passez vos convictions religieuses avant
les valeurs de la république et
effectivement on constate que la
proportion de réponses positives est
plus forte chez les français musulmans
et là en l'occurrence on se focalise
chez les jeunes deux fois plus forte
main d'oeuvre et les musulmans deux fois
plus fort que deux fois plus forte et
que plus les musulmans sont jeunes et
plus à en croire ce sondage ils font
passer leurs convictions religieuses
avant les valeurs de nagusa vers là
dessus soyons extrêmement catégorique
parce que il ya des ventilations très
intéressante dans ce sondage qui figure
qui sont consultables sur le site de la
fondation jean jaurès et sur le site de
l'ifop juillet voire avant l'émission
est comme ça gros échantillons l'ifop a
fait le tri par parmi les français non
musulmans
on a pris les français sans religion non
évidemment eux ils placent les valeurs
de la république au sud la région qu'ils
n'ont pas mais ils sont très nombreux
ensuite vous avez les français
pratiquant irrégulier et les français
pratiquant régulier catholique
catholique régulier alors là on est là
en train de se dire ah oui 40% des
français musulmans placent valeurs de la
religion au sus à la république est bien
pour les catholiques pratiquants
réguliers dans ce même sondage c'est
précisément 41 % au-dessus ku et c est
ça c'est mon point différent là dessus
il trouve que je n'ai pas une très
grande foi religieuse malgré mon
patronyme mais si j'étais croyant ça me
paraîtrait assez logique quand je vous
prends un exemple extrême en privé mais
que peut bien faire comprendre par tout
le monde
je me suis marié civilement ma belle
mère qui est très catholique considère
que je me suis à peine mariée qu'elle
considère comme beaucoup de catholiques
et c'est tout à fait légitime que
leucate le mariage religieux a plus de
valeur que le mariage civil c'est pour
ça que c'est un sacrement c'est le droit
des gens et c'est là où faut faire
attention à la question qui est posée
c'est les valeurs de la république par
rapport aux valeurs leur religion
la plupart des gens qui croient
forcément religion quel quelle soit
place leurs valeurs religieuses en
valeur morale religieuse au dessus
d'avoir la république n'est jamais qu'un
régime politique
c'est tout à fait logique la question
serait beaucoup plus inquiétante les
réponses beaucoup plus inquiétant si on
parlait de l'application des lois de la
république
nous savons très bien dans l'histoire de
france que à la fin du 19e siècle et
bien les catholiques l'église c'était
plus ou moins et progrès très
progressivement rallier aux institutions
du régime en place
c'est à dire la république selon un
autre il serait rallié aussi c'est la
doctrine religieuse classique catholique
classique mais certains ne s'y rallient
à l'est pas au fond de leur coeur mais
il appliquer tous les lois du règle du
régime en place ont le cran la
république et qu'il fallait aller mourir
à la guerre pour défendre et la france
et ce régime il allait mourir
donc la question en réalité politique à
poser n'est pas en réalité de savoir si
on place ses valeurs privées aux valeurs
religieuses au dessus ou en dessous des
valeurs du régime
c est ce qu on accepte d'appliquer les
lois de la république c'est une tout
autre question est là j'espère qu'on
n'aurait pas eu 40 % de gens disons non
moi j'applique les lois de la religion
n'est pas celle de la république là
dessus je veux pas tomber dans l'exemple
extrême et la caricature mais on sait
qu' il y a dans l'histoire de la
république un principe d'égalité femmes
hommes
aujourd'hui revendiquée par tout ce qui
n'a pas toujours était en réalité un une
boussole pour tout le monde et dans
l'égalité femmes hommes il ya un
processus un processus d'émancipation
des femmes qui est passé notamment par
la maîtrise la maîtrise de leur
fécondité et la liberté de disposer de
leur corps et le vote de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse qui a quasiment
1 qu'il ya plus d'un demi-siècle
aujourd'hui a longtemps été critiqué
mais enfin disputer une vive opposition
des milieux catholiques encore
aujourd'hui alors même que évidemment ce
droit existe il existe il existe encore
une fois il s'agit de groupes qui sont
relativement minoritaires isolé mais il
existe encore des groupes qui s'opposent
par des actions militantes assez radical
a voilà le le fait que des ivg puisse
être fait dans certains centres médicaux
donc on voit bien que là encore il
s'agit pour certaines personnes de faire
passer leurs convictions religieuses
leurs convictions religieuses
devant l'affirmation d'un droit garanti
par la loi pour une catégorie de la
population mais met un peu différent si
c'est un peu différent en france est
question centrale pour nombreux
catholiques avaient effectivement le
droit à la vie c'est-à-dire l'avortement
ou bien l'opposition à la pma ou la gpa
si des gens si un jour c'est d'ailleurs
en train de se faire pour la paix mais à
ça se fait ça sera probablement pour la
gpa
si un jour le régime en place en
l'occurrence la république est bien
adopte la liberté totale de pratiquer la
fin de grâce à la liberté si on prétend
si on veut la paix mal et gpa et bien on
ne peut pas empêcher
et c'est tout à fait normal ensemble de
personnes parmi les musulmans d'ailleurs
très souvent parmi les catholiques
également parmi les protestants ou les
juifs de considérer que ben e
leur valeur elles sont au dessus de ça
que ils demeurent opposés à la pma ou à
la gpa effectivement il y aura une
opposition de valeur par rapport au
régime
donc ça c'est tout à fait légitime dans
qu'est ce que dans une société
la vraie différence par rapport à ce que
disent yes et donc la question n'est pas
les opinions ou les valeurs la question
c'est l'opposition en quelque sorte aux
lois en vigueur
des gens qui sont opposés à l'avortement
et qui souhaite que ce soit interdit
c'est leur droit le plus strict à
condition qu'ils se situent dans le
débat démocratique
s'ils vont faire des actions illégales
qui font entre différents militants
prosélyte pour convaincre des personnes
de ne pas mais vous êtes de leur
paraître charles alain portelance des
actions militant contre l'avortement et
les attentats de charlie hebdo va en
aucune façon non nous là on était sur
une généralité qui consiste à dire quel
est le deux poids deux mesures entre nos
propres convictions je vous donne aux
internautes et puis ensuite bien sûr
vous vous continuez à débattre d'abord
on vous a posé la question vous savez
qu'on aime bien aussi nous faire non pas
un sondage car l'échantillon n'est pas
représentatif à part celui du talent et
du discernement de regarder point de vue
mais on vous a posé la question sur
twitter vous reconnaissez-vous dans
l'expression je suis charlie c'est oui à
62 et demi pour cent donc voilà là aussi
il ya débat
beaucoup de réactions sur ce sondage
nathan 770 sur lefigaro.fr qui
considèrent qu'il est intéressant car il
donne là la proportion de la place
qu'occupe l'islam en france on a le
droit de tout dire nous dit dz sur
youtube mais parfois on ferait mieux de
se taire c'est sûrement pas adressé aux
gens qui sont sur ce plateau je vous
rassure tout de suite
christophe 78 sur lefigaro.fr à nouveau
que des gens se refuse à condamner des
attentats me semble vraiment
problématique
et puis encore nathan qui est assez
sombre
pour lui ce sondage condamne toute
perspective de vivre ensemble la
réaction de babineau sans lesquels il
n'y a pas d'émission point de vue digne
de ce nom c'est surtout la jeunesse
musulmane qui a une religiosité plus
forte que ses aînés et qui est donc
moins tolérantes au blasphème sans doute
babineau faisiez-vous allusion à la
partie du sondage que nous avons montré
à l'écran
et puis ce constat la société française
est de plus en plus communautariste et
donc elle est de moins en moins charlie
est ce qu'il ya une partager ce constat
fut très troublée par l'expression je
suis charlie je suis pas sûr que comme
on dirige
c'est une expression bizarre dire je
suis charlie si vous voulez moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour beaucoup de
peine pour effectivement les
journalistes ont été assassinés beaucoup
de respect y compris pour l'acte récent
de charlie de republier ces séries télé
pour eux c'est ça même plus de sens la
seconde fois que la première en quelques
sortes voyez ce que je veux dire mais
dire je suis charlie c'est une
injonction qui est très curieuse charlie
était un journal qui avait calé cave et
qui a toujours une ligne éditoriale qu'à
une pratique etc à laquelle on n'est pas
obligés de s'identifier dire je défends
charlie et je défends la liberté de
charlie des choses dire je suis charlie
c'est quelque chose qui est très
embarrassant parce que de fait pour
ensemble de personnes qui sont attachées
et pas seulement pas seulement
d'ailleurs les musulmans il ya aussi des
pléthorique qui ont encore entre la
gorge cela semble de couverture de de
mise en cause du clergé et caetera et le
redire évidemment qu'ils défendent
charlie contre ce qu'ils auraient été
faits qui défendent la liberté de
charlie mais dire je suis charlie non
voyez ce que je veux dire
demain il y avait l'humanité qui était
avait fait l'objet d'un attentat
je suis pas sûr qu on obligerait tout le
monde à dire je sue l'humanité chaire
jérôme c'est le message citant invitée
sharleen on ne dit pas je revendique
pour moi même la ligne éditoriale durant
les deux on aurait mieux valu dire autre
chose
on comprend quand même que c'est le
message et sait se sublimer ce slogan la
qui a fait florès jeu